In the last video, we talked
about freelancing work,
including new
technology-mediated work
arrangements.
In this video, we're going
to take a look at Uber
as a case study.
Many of you have probably
heard of Uber by now.
Their main business
model is to connect
people who need a
ride with drivers
who are willing to
drive them, using
their own personal vehicle.
And if this sounds suspiciously
like a cab company,
you're right.
Uber competes directly with
traditional cab companies.
In contrast, however, Uber
drivers use their own vehicle.
And this means they're
responsible for the costs
associated with maintenance
and repair, the wear and tear
on their own
vehicle, and largely
fueling their own vehicle.
The main service
provided by Uber
is this technology, which
connects people and facilitates
automatic payments.
Early on, Uber and
companies like it,
were seen as ushering in
a new and very exciting
model of work.
There was high flexibility
in terms of when you worked,
and where you worked.
Uber even claimed early on that
the median salary for a driver,
working at least 40 hours
a week in New York City,
was $90,000 a year.
Since then, people have begun
to challenge these figures.
And darker aspects of work at
Uber have begun to surface.
Uber started out with
higher fares, for example.
But has cut them on
multiple occasions,
in order to try
to better compete
with traditional cab companies.
In fact, there are reports
that UberX drivers, UberX
being the most commonly
used, lowest-cost service,
make only a little bit more
than traditional cab drivers.
And again, these drivers are
responsible for the costs
associated with using
their own vehicle
over extended periods of time.
And there's some evidence
that Uber drivers
are becoming
increasingly disgruntled,
because of this price
cutting, because
of verbal abuse by passengers,
and a perception of apathy
on the part of Uber to
do anything about it.
They're frustrated, as well,
because of the ranking system,
which will essentially
make them lose
their job if their
passenger rating falls
below a certain level.
And some workers in some
areas like California,
have begun to try to organize
and collectively bargain.
So, for example, in
California drivers
formed CADA, the California
App-based Drivers Association.
But these drivers face a tough
and very difficult road ahead.
The US law does not
require Uber to negotiate,
because these drivers
are currently considered
independent contractors.
In other words,
they're not employees
from Uber's point of view.
They're not their problem.
So as it stands,
this association,
the California App-based
Drivers Association,
is trying to bring publicity
to some of these issues.
But it doesn't have very
much leverage beyond that.
So the question that
I would pose to you
as a class is, what
do you recommend
that Uber drivers do to improve
their employment circumstances?
I encourage you to
join in discussion
with your fellow classmates
in the next segment
of this course.